Buffalo Bills player Demar Hamlin is in
critical condition in a Cincinnati
hospital after collapsing on the field
Monday night Hamlin made a hit
he got up took a couple of steps and
this then just fell to the ground
the bills say that Hamlin suffered
cardiac arrest on the field leading to
the postponement of the Monday night
game against the Cincinnati Bengals
Hamlin took a big hit in the chest area
during the first quarter of the game in
a collision with Bengals receiver T
Higgins
Higgins was running up field after a
catch when Hamlin got up after the play
and suddenly collapsed
a statement from the bill says quote
tomorrow Hamlin suffered a cardiac
arrest following a hit in our game
versus the Bengals his heartbeat was
restored on the field and he was
transferred to the UC Medical Center for
further testing and treatment he is
currently sedated and listed in critical
condition
ESPN reports that Hamlin was
administered CPR on the field while
surrounded by teammates as they shielded
him from public viewing according to
ESPN during a conference call NFL
Executive Vice President of football
operations Troy Vincent said look I've
never seen anything like it immediately
my player hat went on how do you resume
play after you've seen such a dramatic
event occur right in front of you
after the incident Higgins sent out his
best wishes to Hamlin on Twitter writing
my prayers and thoughts go to the Hamlin
family I'm praying that you pull through
bro Hamlin's mother Gail who was in
attendance for Monday night's game was
among the fans who traveled from Buffalo
for the game and went to the hospital
following the incident
on Tuesday's episode of Good Morning
America Jordan Rooney a family
spokesperson gave an update on Hamlin's
condition
so I can't speak specifically on his
medical condition I will say is that you
know he's fighting he's a fighter
um you know I felt like in the moment
there needed to be some clarity that you
know he was at a he was awake at that
time and now he's sedated so
um you know the family is in good
spirits we're honestly just taking it
minute by minute hour by hour Hamlin's
family also released a statement
thanking fans for their love and support
shown during this challenging time and
many friends and teammates of Hamlin's
have been sending their best wishes to
the Buffalo Bills defensive back since
moons of this condition spread Josh
Allen quarterback for the bills says
please pray for our brother the bill is
Daquan Jones writes praying with all
that I am for Demar Hamlin and his
family love you bro and ESPN's Ryan
Clark offered his support to Hamlin and
shared his thoughts it's about a young
man at 24 years old that was living his
dream
that a few hours ago was getting ready
to play the biggest game of his NFL
career and there's probably nowhere else
in the world he wanted to be and now he
fights for his life we should remember
that these men are putting their lives
on live to live their dream and tonight
Demar Hamlin's dream became a nightmare
for not only himself but his family and
his entire team